create to create all right welcome to
another Evans book update Nina's here I
wait over here to be home so Nina's here
super exciting this has been interesting
week for me in terms of the book update
I gave it to my publisher and I've
written everything except for the final
chapter and I was supposed to get it
back to me but she hasn't so it's book
writing today and I didn't get it back
so to have anything to write and instead
what I did was create other amazing
things for other problems that I'm
working on and I think about the book
and here's the kind of lesson for you
guys for going into the questions I
think about the book and we've had to
cut half of the book more than half the
book we started that now about half the
book about half the book has been cut
down and I was talking to someone who
helped me review the book is that you
cut out have to block this like 60,000
words that's like was I mod that's like
an entire book you just cut and I'm like
yeah because you know i will throw away
i will create and throw away more than
most people just create and I guess
she's being comfortable with that and
will end up using that stuff if it ends
up being bonus chapters or some other
things on the website it's being
comfortable with throwing stuff away and
I create to create I create not for the
outcome of whatever the results going to
be a creep because I'd love to create
and I take that approach and end up
throwing away a kind of stuff but I'm
also working my creativity muscle to get
better at it to do it faster the next
time and create new ideas and so the
book we've cut out half half it's
totally gone it's down to sixty thousand
words and I have to write five thousand
more words around conclusion but we sort
of like 120 it's on the 60 on top of
that I want to share two other examples
with you of what else I did today I want
to create a video for turnitin salsa
that shows a girl it's called you don't
belong in the bench and a girl kind of
getting off the bench of life to come
and join a dance class and it really
meant to be something that can inspire
people whatever stage the rat in life to
get off the bench of their life to go do
something that they really want to do
and I connect with the body-mind marc
dreier who's been on the
in a couple times from phantom media and
he asked me a couple questions about the
video since that's his business about
him i'm going to connect with him and I
wanted to read a couple the the back and
forth you get an idea of why I'm
creating some of the things and when
most people have like practical
understanding questions I don't always
have practical responses and I sent this
to my team as a way to Nina looks
confused I sent this to my team as a way
to inspire their creativity in their
thinking but I want to share with you
guys as well so the first question was
what's the objective of this campaign
why make this video and i sent him a
link to this asian commercial that was
heartwarming and moving and said this is
the original inspiration and all the
other heartwarming touching
inspirational commercial seem to be
asian i want something to come out of
Toronto I want a moving inspiring piece
that makes people want to what to do
something more with their life I can
contribute to society I want to create
something I can show Hayden my son with
pride and he'll show his children I want
to add value to the world this is
probably an unexpected response right
when someone asks you why are you
creating this product why are you
creating the service you know whatever
you're making your dance class a book
piece of clothing for me it's always I
want to add value to the world and so it
creates a create something that I'm
proud of that I hope will impact a lot
of people and it's not I want to create
this video to generate more sales for my
business because if i take care of the
first grease up the moving and
meaningful powerful I'll take care of
the second in terms of generating sales
his next question was what's the
objective of the video what is the video
itself going accomplished i wrote my aim
is to have people watch reflect and
takes take action on something they've
been on vengeful in their lives second
our objective is to show that people can
accomplish this through dance next
question use where how will be able to
be used and this is another thing right
like a lot of people want to figure out
the whole chain of events before they
create anything so he's asking me how am
I gonna use this video and i wrote i
have no idea how many uses video you
know the initial plans are going to put
on youtube put it on the TV in the
studio with captions put something on
our wall just like disney showcases
their videos if you go visit their
studios something that can be proud of
just stills of it from there who knows i
want to gift the world a great piece of
art more to be discovered I'm sure as we
create and I think this is a super
important point because I don't
know how it's all going to work out but
I have faith that it is going to work
out and if we create something moving
and powerful it's going to help a lot of
people and help our business to target
audience depending on your use you may
have different targets but who is the
audience again another like practical
pains on understandable question the
target rounds for this I wrote humans
people who look at themselves in which
they were more people who are on the
bench and again I want to create
something that that can touch anybody
that the message is relevant to anybody
that I watched it I would inspire myself
that's what I want to ideally create and
then that'll impact my business again
just thinking is maybe beyond a lot of
people who want the kind of tangible
nuts and bolts practical how-to but all
this stuff matters when you create
something that is important and
meaningful moves people it has a big
impact and then I drill down to target
audience and like I'm not as worried
about that humans are my target audience
motivation what's the mindset motivation
pinpoint the difference target audience
I'm reviewing what the audience want to
get other watching the video what would
go watch the video or continue to watch
the video it was important to me so
Claudia is our main actress and I said
I'd like for them to see themselves in
Claudia to feel what she's feeling this
is crucial to realize that they aren't
living life to their most understand
that they were sitting on the bench of
life and that they don't belong there if
the look of all based on objective what
is the next step in the brain sales
process what actually we want to
encourage and I wrote the next step is a
masterpiece that moves people do that
and will create so many actions that we
can't even fathom them right now just
like the entrepreneur trading cards this
is a reference to pour one of the videos
mark talked about these don't trainer
trading cards and I mean he didn't
understand why I was doing it so there's
no practical objectives no outcome and I
didn't I I said I want to create it I
want to create this because I think it's
going to be impactful a meaningful and
now looking back and got me connections
to Tim Ferriss and Seth Godin a bunch of
you know big-name bloggers it helped us
raise a hundred thousand dollars for
entrepreneurs in Africa for charity had
a bunch of been his vet business benefit
but when I created it I didn't know what
that outcome was going to be and so just
like the entrepreneur trading cards it
will help our business in ways we
haven't even thought of yet but only if
we can deliver a moving video I'm not so
worried about what the outcome is going
to be I'm not so worried about what the
action is going to be
because they too many people focus just
on that take having somebody taking
action meanwhile your entire product
service whatever you're creating just
isn't good enough just isn't moving
people that's what I want to focus on if
I create a moving experience that you
watch and you get absorbed into you want
to share we're going to have so many
positive business benefits that a lot of
them I can't even think of where this is
going to go so I'm worried about like my
focus is create a masterpiece that was
it so I spent time working with mark on
that the other thing was I was getting
into it with sage a little bit sage is
one of my clients you guys have seen the
Stephen Kelly kind of promos and one of
the things I keep pushing them to do is
is being more visionary with their
marketing being more visionary with
their with their advertising their
campaigns and so I had a little bit of
time today and so I created campaign for
sage one sage one is their accounting
software that is meant for startups pure
beginners and one of the things that
they want to do was try to be a seen as
a champion of entrepreneurs Bri helping
entrepreneurs to believe in
entrepreneurs and so first of all I
thought stage one was a super boring
name but I tried to figure out as I was
driving my parents back from the airport
today how can we take stage one and turn
it into something and the campaign that
I thought of was I'm someone so sage one
someone and helping entrepreneurs
believe in themselves and showing
entrepreneur who had haters in their lab
the little man in their life trying to
beat them down and they tinued on and
persevered through and this is what I
made in half an hour take the webcam you
guys see oh it's all backwards no it's
backwards okay anyway so this is jessica
alba and it says even my husband caps
thought the idea was too big I'm someone
and then have this each one local so
sage wants someone i know it's backwards
for people just joining I know it's
backwards Oprah she was fired from her
job as a news anchor because they told
her she wasn't fit for television I'm
someone sage one he was fired for a
newspaper for lacking imagination have
no original ideas well Disney I'm
someone sage one they will not run with
this they were but if they did it'd be
the most visionary interesting thing
that has ever come out of sage in their
marketing campaigns and I'm trying to
push them towards doing more and more
and more more and I think somebody might
ask me why am I doing this like if I
know that they're never
use this why would I create it and I
create to create I created as a gift to
them and I shared this with some of my
team hopefully get inspired I'm sharing
with you guys maybe inspire something in
you I come up with ideas and I create to
create regardless of warned about the
outcome because if I only focus on the
outcome then the outcome is almost never
what you think it's going to be I think
that's one lessons because the outcome
that I want is probably not working I'm
going to get regardless did we losing
you oh I'll Nina slowly moving out just
tuning out like we're going to the
questions next I don't any value to you
add value by being here right as I you
just by being here being comfortable
throwing stuff away not having to have
everything have a practical logical
understandable outcome that creating
something amazing is a gift to yourself
to your spirit into the people around
you into the world around you regardless
of the outcome and that was my theme
today because I had extra time because
it wasn't running my book and that's it
great create the create that's it I'm
done for my rant ok questions we got
some questions coming in trusting your
gut otherwise known as your intuition is
how I've gotten to where I am right now
no matter how bad things get for me the
1i wavering thought I have is that I'm
supposed to be running my own businesses
and that I'm going to be successful at
it questions or Evan Shire do you think
you'll want to start your own media
group eventually mr. Vaynerchuk has a
wildly successful YouTube channel before
full moons own media group and you see
yourself going that way you love making
videos so it makes evolutionary sense
the bowl so that is something more
all-encompassing won't be something
required to help your one being
entrepreneurs your tenacity is inspiring
keep going friend this is another thing
where I don't try to plan too far ahead
and I end up going in strange direction
right I follow my flow and it leaves me
off on paths I don't right now see
myself becoming an agency like Gary's
built right he's built an agency where
he then works with clients when their
social media campaigns I could see
myself one of the things that I've I
have like a plan for would have enacted
on yet is helping other up-and-coming
youtubers who want to make a difference
in giving them guidance mentorship
coaching
and helping them build a business
there's a lot of people have a lot of
talent who have a lot of heart who don't
know how to put the pieces together and
who need help in the training on how to
be on camera in the topics to cover in
how to promote their videos in how to
land corporate sponsorships and book
deals and all that stuff and for me more
and more what I'm trying to do is work
with people who want to have that
positive impact in the world it's
important to me is what I'm striving to
do so I can help bring along other
youtubers who have a powerful mission
and then they can go impact millions of
people too that's high leverage and a
good use of my time I just don't have
the time right now to do it and I could
create it you know it's an excuse I'm
just not ready for right now so that's
up somewhere I see it potentially going
is building a network of entrepreneurs
who are all on a mission who want to
help each other out and help the planet
out in some way and coaching them and
guiding them along their path so I could
see that happening I don't see myself
going down in agency route though where
I'm creating Facebook campaigns and
youtube campaigns for brands it's really
not what I want to do even in the brain
deals that I do now it's not about that
it's always about the audience when I
have Stephen Kelly come on and talk
about entrepreneurship but it's never
about how great sages or why you should
go by sage accounting it's about you
guys helping answer your questions
helping you build your business for the
companies who want me just to pitch
their stuff I always say no which is why
I haven't seen any of that on my channel
of stuff that I do so I don't think
being a marketing agency is where I'm
going to go but helping work with and
inspire entrepreneurs weather like local
entrepreneurs here in my city or YouTube
entrepreneurs to build something
powerful I could see that definitely
happening ok and a young deer Evan it
keeps me motivated to see you motor and
passionate does it motivate you to see
the people around you motivated do you
think you think I competitive when you
see people good I don't know what the
video you want to be what they played it
too when you see so when you see people
are motivated around you do you get
motivated yeah it was with you I'm i can
answer but what's your answer no if I
see people around me doesn't look too
fate me see people more motivated around
you doesn't motivate you should leave
his job in some some value bombs and
so for me it's a yes for me you know i
find i find this a couple of types of
people around me right now one is I
don't find too many people around me who
are more motivated than me and that's
actually bad that's bad because there's
nobody there pushing me driving me to
want to go and do more that's why I
created the top 10 series in the end
special series extra motivation for me
to feel like I'm being surrounded by
Steve Jobs of Disney and Martha Stewart
and Bill Gates and these icons so a
little bit of their magic pixie dust
rubs off onto me and gets me more
motivated to do things the two people
that I then do see a lot of our one the
people who are you know they want to do
stuff but they have they have blocks and
they have limited beliefs and all these
reasons why they can't go off and do
something greater and bigger and better
and more amazing and awesome and
contribute and then they they either
open never seen feedback or they're not
of the ones who are not it's usually a
quick into the conversation and for the
ones who are if you if you take like a
little bit if I see a little bit of
energy coming back from you that's all I
need it's game over we'll be talking for
hours you don't Nina woke up on Ethan
say okay finally go home it's been three
hours here talking like if you are a
little bit open to change and thinking
bigger and being honest and clicking
through your walls man it's like that
conversation will go on I'll forget to
go to the bathroom and I'll forget the
that motivates me to know when because I
want to see you off doing something it's
extremely unmotivating though when you
don't do anything like a lot of people
can talk a big game and get inspired and
then they don't actually take action I
helped bust through in that moment and
they don't take any action and the next
day they wake up and they're back to
their old habits and routines and so a
critical piece for you guys is any time
you feel you're in that moment of
excitement and boldness and feel like
you can you can break through do it now
whether you're watching this video or
you're watching something else you read
a book your tend to seminar whatever it
is you get excited about something take
immediate action on it don't wait you
know I'm driving home from from my
parents in the airport and I got that
idea for the sage campaign and I just
started creating it and in half an
our I had those pictures done so when
you get those moments act now don't wait
because you won't do it tomorrow you'll
fall back to your limiting beliefs again
but definitely being around people who
are motivated gets me excited and last
question okay this one came from
facebook claw be celestine next to see
the coming of Evans book what give you
the inspiration to write this book and
what message do you want to share to
your audience through this book you
can't say what the name is oh yeah they
don't know the name is yeah well you
have to say about this I don't even know
to what's your book okay so I never
wanted to write a book going in so I
have an agent who represents me on on
deals trust and get brand deals and
speaking gigs and that kind of stuff and
he was convinced him needed a book and I
said I don't need a book most people
want a book because they needed for
credibility because they needed open
doors because they need it for branding
all of these things they need to get
media I don't need that like my youtube
channel my website can open up just as
many doors are more than then in having
a book is our book would and so I didn't
need it for the ego play some people
just want to have a book to their name
it's like under bucket list of dreams
and i totally get down and understand
that just not on my list and so I didn't
want to write a book he said no no no
youna book you have to have a book I'm
gonna help you get a book I'm gonna get
you a book deal like okay well whatever
we'll start it and then the book topic
that I had was around modeling success
and how I did it and it just felt like I
was going through the motions and I
wasn't really wasn't really interesting
the book on it and then halfway to the
proposal to the publishers or to my my
book agent sorry I changed it I changed
the idea for the book that's something
that I was super passionate about like
oh I gotta book on this I gotta read a
book on this this is one like the like
balls or not like I need to write a book
on this this is going to be so awesome
and they hated it they hated the idea
they said that's not a book that's like
a worksheet that's like a workbook it's
not it's not it's not big enough to fill
a book Zig are you guys nuts how do you
not see this this is an amazing book is
that now the publishers will never want
that and and I convinced them like
listen I'm this is a book if you want to
do a book with me this is what I'm
riding on take it or leave it and it
said okay let's do it and we pitched the
publishers and we had we've had five
calls eating two days all pretty much
back to back end up getting offers from
three and then pushed one kind of
negotiate against each other too
to the final offer and I'm super happy
with the publisher that I'm working with
right now I only wanted to work with the
mainstream publisher because again the
stuff that I work on I wanted to have a
major impact it has to have the ability
to reach millions of people i'm not
interested in doing it and people were
saying well you can make a lot more
money if you self-publish and put it up
you don't make a lot of money from in
the pocket that's okay I don't need to
make a lot of money from writing the
book that's not my goal my goal is
impact my goal is not money if I make a
lot of impact I'll make a lot of money
that's not understanding the the hell
but understand the why why I'm doing
this is important I'm going to create
amazing things and if I do that then I'm
going to make money and I don't know how
it's going to happen but it's going to
happen having having belief in that and
it's always worked out and it always
will and so I only want to work with a
major publisher and that's why I started
writing the book and it's been this is
week 40 of me recording the process I
don't remember when I actually started
how many what like what week one was in
the video should go back and see and
then what's the message you want to
share to your audience throughout the
book can talk with the message ya can
talk about the message yet it's coming
it's coming message will be coming soon
cool well that's it mean why sit down
you gotta send up you gotta say goodbye
take you guys who are watching if you
have a question about the topic today
because create to create or question
about my book the book writing process
leaving it comes to below I'll answer in
the next video thank you guys so much
for watching really appreciate but when
I do this I block you ah really
appreciate it yeah that's it guys thank
you again for watching continue to
believe and write whatever you have i
usually ended in it will see you soon Oh
see this is how long I haven't seen you
in your video should be on more often or
by Evan okay see ya